that's why it's so interesting to see  mike tyson's make the switch  it's clear that like whatever that is  however that fight goes he made us  there's a switch of a dif he stepped  into a different dimension  roy jones jr is coming on my podcast  soon and uh you know roy's gonna be on  uh before the fight i'm  i'm so curious to see how it goes down  but genuinely concerned  because mike tyson is a heavyweight and  roy jones at his best was  pounds and um i don't know if roy has  that room in his house mental house of  where mike tyson goes  i don't know i don't know if he has a  rope mike doesn't have a room  he's got an empire in there with the  open side  there's a whole empire in his head and  he's he's in that  firmly you know when he got out of the  weed and and  started training again like you could  see it in him and by the way  physically in person looks spectacular  he looks like a [ __ ] adonis i mean he  looks ready to go  it's crazy yeah watching videos of him  you